Hello everybody.
We've got a full house
Thank you all for coming
and welcome to this talk
about Project Tango and area
learning.
So my name is Wim Meeussen and I
lead the Project Tango location
team.
So today I will talk
about area learning,
which is one of the core
technologies of Project Tango.
And it's at the foundation
of almost everything we're
working on my team,
so it's something
I really deeply care about.
And it's exciting that today
I can spend a whole session
on area learning.
And if you have no idea what
area learning is, that's OK.
We'll cover that in this talk.
And so let's get started with
an overview of the key things
that you will
learn in this talk.
So number one, by
the end of this talk,
you will be able to build an
augmented reality application,
where you can put virtual
objects in the world,
and they will stay in place,
and they will not drift away.
So if you have built
AR applications before,
you know this is
a really big deal.
And I'll have a live
demo where I'll show you
how I place these
objects and how they stay
in place in the environment.
Number two, by the
end of this session,
you will know how to build
multiplayer experiences, where
multiple Tango devices
interact with each other.
And this is obviously
without any wiring,
without any infrastructure
in your environment.
It just works with just
your mobile device.
And then finally, I'll talk
about some future applications
where you could imagine that
you just never get lost anymore
in large buildings.
So I always like to start
out with a quick poll
to get a little more
background about you.
So by a raise of
hands, like how many of
you have heard about
Project Tango before today?
All right, that's most people.
How many people know
about area learning?
That's just a handful.
And how many of you are
here because it's just
really hot outside?
A few honest people.
All right.
So today I really
want you to come away
with a really good understanding
of what area learning is,
how it works, and
also how you can
use area learning to
build new applications
and enable new user experiences.
So I'll start out with a
quick, high-level overview
of what Project Tango
is, for those of you
who are still new to Tango.
So fundamentally, Tango is
about enabling mobile devices
to understand the
world around them.
So Tango uses computer
vision for your device
to understand the
geometry of the world,
but also to know its own
position and orientation
in that world.
So in some sense,
it turns your screen
into an extension
of the real world,
like your screen becomes
this magic window
into the real world.
And if you look at
the example here,
so think about this
device, if it understands
what the world
around it looks like,
and it knows where
it is in that world,
it can start displaying some
really interesting content
about the world.
You could imagine you
can display directions
on how to get from
A to B. Or you
could display virtual
furniture in your house
and you can go look at it
from all different angles
to see how it would fit.
Or you can imagine you can
have a game that just plays out
right in your living room.
So Tango can enable whole new
range of applications that just
simply weren't possible before.
So let's look at the three main
technologies of Project Tango.
So there is motion
tracking, depth perception,
and area learning.
And if you have attended
talks about Tango before,
you've probably heard a
lot about those first two.
And today, we'll mostly
focus on the third one,
on area learning.
But let's do a quick overview
for all three of them.
So motion tracking is all
about allowing your device
to know how it moves
through the world.
So as a developer,
you can use motion
tracking to know how
your device moved
relative to where it started.
So if, for example, I started
here, and I move one meter,
I can ask the motion
tracking component
how far did you move relative
to where you started.
If I move back to
my original place,
I can ask motion
tracking where I am,
and it will tell me that
I'm back where I started.
So motion tracking is all
about allowing developers
to ask the device how
it's moving through space.
Then depth perception.
So every Tango-enabled
device or every Tango phone
has a special 3D camera.
So with this 3D camera,
the Tango device
can sense the 3D geometry
of the world around it.
So if I point my device
at the speaker desk here,
it could sense this geometry
of the front of the desk.
If I point it at the
back of the desk,
it would sense the geometry
of the back of the desk.
So wherever I point it, it
can sense the 3D geometry.
And as a developer, you can
carry that 3D information
in the form of 3D point clouds.
So then the last core
technology, area learning, this
is what really gives your
Tango device a memory.
And it works in a very
similar way to how people
operate in the real world.
So remember when you came
into this dome or tent thing,
probably, in the
back of your head,
you started building up a model
of what the space looked like.
You saw a speaker desk.
There's two big screens.
There's a lot of chairs.
And you take that mental
model and you store it
in your memory.
So imagine now, if you
would leave the room,
let's say you go
to the restroom.
And when you come
back later, you
would quickly recognize that
you're in the same space
because you recognize the desk
and the screens and the chairs.
So you would recognize that
you're back in that same space.
And Tango area learning
works in a very similar way.
So when you bring a Tango
device into a new space,
it will use its camera
to look at the world
and compute this mathematical
description of what
the world looks like.
And it'll store that
mathematical description
in its memory.
And when you then
bring that same Tango
device in the same
room at a later time,
it will be able to compare
what it sees with its camera
to that mathematical
description it stored in memory.
And when those two match
up, it recognizes space
and it knows exactly
where it is in that space.
So let's dive a little deeper
into the details of how
area learning works and even
how Tango works under the hood.
So Tango has this
wide angle camera
that it uses to
look at the world.
So it's much like, in
this example, when you're
visiting a mall,
your Tango device
will look at a few key landmarks
that it sees in the world.
So for example here,
on your left side,
you see that vending
machine, in front of you
there are some restrooms,
and then there's
another landmark
on top of the roof.
So now what happens,
when you start
moving in this
environment, and you
keep looking at those same
landmarks, what happens
is you see those landmarks all
of sudden in different places
in your field of view.
So if you, for example, look
at that vending machine,
initially, it was
on your left side.
And as you move, at the
end, the vending machine
is almost right in front of you.
And this is exactly how
Tango motion tracking works.
Tango will look at all
these landmarks in the world
and see how they move
as the device moves.
And based on that motion, it
can compute its own motion
in space.
So this is pure motion tracking.
So this is still all
without any memory.
So in this example,
if you're in the mall,
if you would cover your eyes,
spin around, and open your eyes
again, you would
have no idea where
you are because you didn't
have any memory of that space.
And the same-- every time you
start Tango motion tracking,
it doesn't have any memory, so
it always starts from scratch.
So let's now think about what
if we add memory to this.
So for a Tango
device, it doesn't
need to remember the entire
image of what it sees,
it only needs to remember
those key landmarks
that it's tracking.
So in this case, it would look
at the small square patch,
like the little yellow
squares around each landmark,
to store a mathematical
description of what exactly
that landmark looks like.
So your Tango
device doesn't care
about the rest of the image.
It just looks at
those landmarks.
So Tango will store two
things in its memory.
One is where it
saw that landmark.
And the second is that
mathematical description
of what that
landmark looks like.
And this is how Tango
can remember its space.
So let's jump to a live
demo, so you can actually
see how this works
under the hood.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So I'll first just start
up Tango motion tracking.
So here, if you look at the
left side of the screen,
you get to see how Tango
is looking at the world.
You get to see yourself,
if you want to.
And all those dots
on the screen, those
are the landmarks
that Tango is seeing
and that Tango is tracking.
So instead of just looking
at like two or three
or four points in
the world, Tango
can look at 100 points
at the same time.
And as I move, Tango keeps track
of how all those landmarks move
in the image.
If you then look at the right
hand side of the screen,
it's kind of a top down
view of where I am.
So if I walk in a
big circle here,
you can see that motion
tracking knows exactly
that I walked in that
circle, and that I
ended up back where I started.
So this is motion
tracking under the hood.
So let's now jump
to area learning.
So initially, this
looks very similar.
You just have Tango
looking out into the world.
But now, Tango is actually
building up a memory
of what the space looks like.
And once it has
created the memory--
so it has happened now-- you see
all these static yellow dots.
Those are the landmarks
that Tango has remembered.
So I can go look at them
from all different angles.
They're literally physical
points in the world
that Tango has
stored in its memory.
And on the right hand side,
you see these lines coming out
of the device.
That is showing where Tango
recognizes a landmark that's
stored in its memory.
So now we can do
something really cool.
So let's say I cover
the cameras here,
so my device has no
idea where it is.
I'll just go hide
it somewhere else.
So now, it should
be completely lost.
But if I point it back at
the area that it learned,
you can see all those landmarks
popped back into place.
So it actually remembered where
it was, based on that memory.
So let me just do
that one more time.
So now, it doesn't
know where it is.
And then you see it jump,
and all the yellow dots
are back in place.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah.
It's pretty cool, right?
So this is really a
view under the hood
of how Tango operates,
for both motion tracking
and for area learning.
So now let's look
a little bit at how
we can use area learning.
So you have a pretty good
understanding of how it works.
And let's see what
can it do for you,
like what kind of
new experiences
can area learning enable?
And let's first
cover an AR example.
So let's say you want to put
a virtual chair in your dining
room.
You want to see how it fits.
The problem you're having
here is that that chair
will start drifting over time.
And that is because if you
just have motion tracking,
you'll have very
small errors that
slowly accumulate over time.
And if you walk around
enough, your chair
might look something like this.
So it'll slowly drift
and drift and drift.
So this is exactly the
problem that we want
to solve with area learning.
You want your chair to
go back right there.
So the way area
learning can help here
is it can build up a
memory of where you
placed a chair in the world.
So it can remember where
exactly you placed that chair.
So even though if
motion tracking slowly
drifts, because Tango remembers
where you placed that chair,
it can always correct it
and put the chair right back
in the right place.
And I'll have a live demo of
this coming up a little later.
So it's actually
pretty cool to see.
So there's obviously a number
of other AR based examples.
Like let's say you're
using the 3D sensor
to start measuring the
geometry of your world.
If you have these nice yellow
annotations on your world,
you want them to stay
exactly in the right place.
You don't want them to
start drifting around.
So this is, again, where
area learning can help.
And even if you have an example
where your objects aren't
static-- for example, you have
these monsters running around--
you still do care that
your virtual world
and your real world stay
aligned with each other.
Because if you would start
drifting, at some point,
your monsters would start
running through the shelves
and you really want them to
stay in the center aisle.
So even here, with
moving objects,
you do care about
that alignment.
So again, area
learning can help here.
And now let's jump to
the second big use case.
That is multiplayer experiences.
So the problem here
is pretty obvious.
You want to know where all the
other players are in the world.
And it would be awesome
if you can do it
without needing to put in
cables or infrastructure
in your environment.
So how can area
learning help here?
So the key for
multiplayer experiences
is to have a memory
of your space,
and to share that memory
between all the devices.
So when all your devices have
the same memory-- so here,
this is the display of what your
device could have memorized.
If all your devices
share that memory,
they could all start recognizing
where they are in that space.
And in some sense, you
turn the real world
in your way to tie all these
Tango devices together.
We don't need any
special infrastructure.
Like you're using your
couch and your carpet
and the poster on the wall.
And they literally tie together
this multiplayer experience.
So let's look a little bit at
how this actually turns out
in the real world because
the real world is always
a little more messy.
So I'll give a
number of examples
where Tango will have some
challenges with area learning.
And it will give you a bit of
a better understanding of where
to best apply area learning.
So if you look at
these two images here,
the left side could be what
your room usually looks like.
And on the right is
probably what you
want your room to look like.
And if you and me
look at these images,
we can kind of recognize that
it's probably the same room.
You see there's maybe
the same shelves.
There are some hangers
that you recognize,
so pretty sure the same place.
But for a Tango
device, those look
like two completely
different spaces
because Tango has built up
all these landmarks on top
of the clothes and everywhere.
If all the clothes move, all
these landmarks have moved,
and Tango would get confused.
So it's kind of like--
imagine you're walking around
in San Francisco,
and you're looking
at some of the big
skyscrapers to kind of keep
yourself oriented.
And then someone comes in
and moves all the skyscrapers
around.
You'd be pretty lost.
So this is really what
happens to Tango when stuff
in the environment moves a lot.
So here's an example
where things didn't move,
but one image was taken
in day and one at night.
So even though your landmarks
are in the same place,
they could actually
look differently
because of the lighting
and because of shadows.
And something that everyone
that has played with cameras
will probably
recognize, if you have
a dark room and a
really bright window,
you have troubles
with your exposure.
You either need to tune in
on the window or on the room,
but you cannot
have it both ways.
And this should
be pretty obvious.
If you have large crowds,
they can make a space look
very differently.
And then another kind
of extreme example.
Tango looks for visually
interesting things
in the world.
And if your room is all
white or all one color,
there's nothing
visually interesting.
There's no landmarks
for Tango to recognize.
So that will be a
challenging space.
If you go outside,
you can imagine
a lot more different changes--
seasons, weather, sunshine,
shadows-- so outside gets
a little more challenging.
So the question
now is, how do you
deal with all these challenges?
And the key point here is time.
Like if you look at a
lot of these changes
that we talked about, those
happen slowly over time.
And some environments
will change quickly
and some will
change very slowly.
Like you could imagine a museum
that has the same exhibition
year round, and maybe it
has very constant lighting,
there, your memory will be
good for months and months
at a time.
And at the other
extreme of the scale,
you could imagine
a subway station
with lots of people
running around.
Maybe there's
advertisements that change,
so there, your memory would
be valid for a lot shorter
of a time.
So a really good strategy
to deal with this
is to build your applications
relying on a short-term memory.
So if you think about
your AR application
where you want to show virtual
furniture in your house,
maybe you want to look at
it for like 20, 30 minutes.
But then during
those 30 minutes,
your house is not
going to change.
So you're good there.
But if you want to play a
multiplayer game in your living
room, maybe you want to
play for a couple of hours.
But during that time,
your living room's
still going to be
your living room.
If you rely on
shorter term memory,
area learning can be a very
powerful and reliable tool.
So let's get to the-- oh,
let's actually play this video.
So this is a real world example
of area learning being used.
So this video was recorded
in the Zurich train station.
And if you look
at the video, you
can see a lot of the challenges
that we just talked about.
There's some outdoors.
There are some
shadows that you see.
There's people walking around.
You can see the floors
are kind of one color.
But then still, area
learning can actually
work in this environment.
So area learning can be
pretty robust to a number
of these changes.
It's just, the
examples I showed were
kind of extreme to kind
of drive the point home.
But you can see how it actually
operates in the real world.
And I'll go a little
further in this video
because there's actually
something cool that
maybe isn't always obvious.
Because Tango fully
works in 3D, you
can actually go
down stairs, and it
will tell you in
full three dimensions
where you are in the world.
So let's look a
little bit at how
to build an application
with area learning.
And again, I'll
cover two examples.
I'll have the AR example
with drift correction,
and I'll have the
multiplayer example.
So first one, you want
to use memory here
to keep all your virtual objects
exactly in the same place.
So this is where your learning
will help you build this.
And for this example,
I will assume you have
an application that uses AR.
And I'll tell you how to
transition it to area learning.
If you don't yet know how
to build an AR application,
Friday morning,
Eitan Marder-Eppstein
has a really interesting talk
about how to build a full AR
end-to-end example using Tango.
So if you're interested
in that, definitely
go check out his talk.
But here, I will assume you
have your application already.
And we're going to port it
to move to area learning.
And the point of
this slide is just
to show you it is really easy.
You need to change
literally two lines of code.
In the first highlighted line,
you just tell Tango, please
enable drift correction.
In the second
line, you will tell
Tango, instead of measuring
where your device is
relative to where you
started, measure it
relative to this memory
that we'll build up.
With just those two lines,
you can transition an app
from regular AR to
area learning AR.
Let me show you a demo
of how that works.
So I'll show the same app,
first without area learning
and then with area learning.
So this is a little
AR app that allows
me to place a really large
cube on top of things.
So we are not using
area learning,
but the cube is
pretty-- it stays
in place pretty reasonable.
But now if I'm a little more
mean, and I move around,
you can see it's still
more or less there.
And if I did a little more
extreme, at some point,
I will lose my cube because it
just doesn't remember anymore
where it is.
So let's now do the
exact same thing,
but with area learning enabled.
So now in the background,
Tango is actually
building up that memory of what
this speaker desk looks like.
So now let me place
the cube back.
So now we can do the same thing.
I can shake the device.
And if I look back, as soon
as it recognizes the space,
it can put the cube back
exactly in the right place.
I can do my previous example
where I cover the camera.
Let the app get completely lost.
And then when I open it back,
as soon as it recognizes it,
it can put the cube back
in exactly the right place.
So you can have applications
where your virtual objects will
stay where they are.
Even if your session
breaks, even if your users
do something crazy,
your virtual objects
will stay in the same place.
[APPLAUSE]
So let's jump to
the next example.
How do we build a
multiplayer game?
So this is a little
bit more involved.
It includes three
different steps.
So first, we will create
a memory of, let's say,
your living room.
Then we will share that
memory with all the devices.
And then you play your game.
Let's first think about how
do you create that memory.
So what that means,
in your shared space,
you want to build up,
literally, this memory
of what that space looks like.
So how do you do that
in code in Tango?
Very simple.
You tell Tango start
learning the area.
And then when you're
done, you say save.
And then you have
built up a memory
of what that space looked like.
So now, how to share that memory
between your different devices.
Again, pretty simple.
Tango has an export and
an import functionality.
So you can export your
memory from one device
and import it on all
the other devices.
So once you have all
your devices set up,
you're ready to go play.
So what area learning has
done, or what building up
that memory has done, is
created this one reference frame
that can be used by all
the different devices,
because that entire memory
is all referenced from one
frame in your environment.
So every single device
in your multiplayer game
can directly ask Tango where
am I relative to this memory.
And if you have multiple
devices using the same memory,
they will all get a reference
relative to that same reference
frame.
And this is how you
run that in Tango code.
You just tell Tango
please use this memory.
And then you start asking
Tango, where are you
relative to this memory.
So the code all
looks pretty simple.
So now I wanted
to share a video.
But I wanted to introduce
the video a little,
because I think it's
easy to underappreciate
the awesomeness of the video.
So the setting is exactly
this picture here.
So we have three players
that have a Tango
device in front of their face.
So they're completely
in a virtual world.
They cannot see each other.
And the video
you're going to see
is showing that virtual world
of one what one of the players
is seeing.
And one of the key things
you should look out
for, in that video, you
will see a Tango device.
And obviously, it's a
virtual Tango device
because it's a virtual world.
But that device is
actually exactly a match
on a real device that's
in the real world.
And you'll see different players
hand that device to each other.
So think about how
awesome that is.
The players can only
see their virtual world,
so only if they know exactly
where all the other players
are, and they know exactly where
that device is, only then can
they do this
comfortable handoff.
So it's pretty amazing.
So check it out.
So this is filmed
from the third person.
So even the third
person is moving around.
And you see how the other two
are just casually handing off
the Tango device from
one to the other.
So this is only possible
with registration between all
those different components.
So you have two players, you
have the person filming it,
and then the Tango device.
You have four different
devices tightly
coordinated with each
other, so pretty amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
And then this is an
example of using VR.
If you want to try something
like this for yourself,
tomorrow night in the
Project Tango after hours,
we have an AR
multiplayer game set up.
So you can go try it out.
And also, if you want
to just try Tango demos,
the sandbox is there
for all three days.
So go test it out.
We have a lot of
cool stuff going on.
Now that I'm advertising
a number of things,
there's two more
Tango talks coming up.
So tomorrow at
3:00 PM, Johnny Lee
will be talking about everything
that's new within Tango.
So definitely go check that out.
And then on Friday,
Friday morning, Eitan
will be talking about how
to build an AR application.
So two more exciting
talks coming up.
So what's next for Tango and
what's next for area learning?
What's coming up?
So I hope, by seeing the
demos, you have been wondering,
like, when can I try this?
And today I'm
excited to announce
that everything
you've seen until now
will be part of our release
coming out next month.
So, yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
So you'll be able to build these
drift-free, drift-corrected AR
experiences.
And you'll be able to build
multiplayer experiences.
And this release is just a
beginning for area learning.
The Tango team will
keep improving,
and we'll keep building better
and more robust algorithms.
So this is just
the very beginning.
And as developers, you're
getting a very early preview
in what area learning can do.
So this is the start
of what will become
a pretty exciting journey.
So let's take a little look
at where this journey could
take us next.
Let's look a little bit
at future applications.
So here, imagine
you're visiting a mall.
And you're trying to figure
out where you are in that mall.
So you pop out your phone,
you start up Google Maps,
and then you get
to see something
like the image on the left.
So you get a really nice
floor plan of the mall,
and then you see this big blue
circle that tells you you're
somewhere here, but we don't
quite know exactly where.
So now imagine what you
could do with area learning.
So imagine if your device could
recognize exactly where it
is in that mall.
You could pinpoint
your location.
And your experience could
look a lot like the image
on the right side, where
you have an exact location,
you even know exactly which
direction you're facing.
And if you take this
one step further,
if you combine that
very accurate location
with augmented reality,
you can imagine
that you can get really
accurate directions on how
to get from where you
are to, let's say,
your favorite store in the mall.
All augmented in the real world.
So I hope this
gives you some idea
of where area your learning
can take us in the future
and that you realize we're just
at the very beginning of what
this technology can do.
And then obviously,
we're not only
at the very beginning of
technologies like area
learning, we're also at the very
beginning of the Tango device
ecosystem.
So you have all seen
the Yellowstone devices,
which is our developer kit.
There's like thousands of those
in the hands of developers
out in the world.
Now Tango has partnered
up with Lenovo.
So Lenovo will be releasing
the first consumer-facing
Tango-enabled phone.
It will be coming out later
this year as a worldwide launch.
[APPLAUSE]
So I hope-- I want
to end with this.
I hope you realize
that this is actually
a really great and amazing
time to be part of Tango
and be a Tango developer.
We have a lot of new
technologies coming out.
There's new devices coming out.
And I think that we really
have this unique opportunity
to redefine how people
interact with their phones,
and even how phones
interact with the world.
So I'm pretty excited to see
what we can build together.
Cool.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]